Hey YouTubers it's Charlie so this is going
be my first preview for walking dead season
six we finally have a little bit of footage
from the set and the cast was at the Saturn
awards this past weekend talking little bit
about what's going to be going on the only
thing we don't have yet is an official trailer
they usually wait till the comic con panel
to show that off what I'm going to do is play
this short clip from the set of episode one
is just you know Michael Cudlitz walking around
talking to people they don't answer a whole
lot of big questions but there are some important
things going on in the background that I'm
going to use to do a breakdown so just
be sure to look around in the frame at
what the cast is doing Hi guys, it's Mike Cudlitz here on the set of The Walking Dead. It's season six episode
one huge huge episode it's amazing c'mon with
me we're going to go talk to some of the cast
about coming back to Georgia We ended on a really compelling
note so I'm excited to get to get going I hope
that we find out a lot more about these wolves. What do you think is going to happen there? We'll see, you'll see, I don't know, we have no idea We're here onset with Lennie James
is back with us, Morgan, What's it like to be back? It's a little surreal, I'm not going to lie to you, t's a little like I've been here forever and I've
never been here.You got pretty epic with the stick. Are we maybe going to find out a little bit more about that storyline?
Do we not know? I think I know but I'm not sure. Let's go see if we can sneak up on some other
people and maybe eavesdrop on what's going on. Hey, hi, it's Lauren, it's me. What's it like being back in Georgia?It's so funny, as soon as you say hello to every face, you feel like you were just here as soon as you've sweated and maybe had three cups of coffee
we're back. you moment to talk directly to the fan's 30
million people in the she let me is is that
announce I'm sure I don't laughter when she
and the more truck the day is like family
did you mean you know it's amazing to of course
thank you so much back excited back Norman:
is that he yelled as he me on the is is he
will the comments I read arrearages want to
thank you for showing up and spending the
day with us for having a blast season six
is can be phenomenal the first episode is
below your mind thank you so really the biggest
thing about this you are not Norman Reedus
walking around kissing everyone is Morgan
Morgan is going to be big when the show comes
back Lennie James is always a lot of fun but
he still the lead actor on another show called
critical it's only 13 episodes of season so
if he gets renewed I don't I don't think alive
any problems bouncing back and forth between
walking dead assuming that at some point this
season he's going to leave the cast hopefully
he doesn't die and I'd love to see him stick
around and it would be great if he stuck around
all the way through season seven it is that
I don't think this of the show is going to
cause problems with that the give you let
the show it would be because of scheduling
problems I think the always had the intention
of bringing them back it just that your before
last season when we saw him a couple times
there were really bad scheduling problems
like he had a bunch of other stuff he was
doing some of that got canceled so naturally
use like okay I'm available why don't you
bring back the walking dead so Scott Gimple's
like hell yeah I'll bring you back they have
released some key art for episode one is big
poster with Morgan brick front and center
it gives you pretty good idea of what the
dynamic is going to be between them it's like
on one side you have Saison people any of
the survivors on the other in between them
is crazy Rick in Jedi Morgan it's like there's
going to be a line drawn in the sand or anything
like that it seems like what they want you
to think is that Morgan is going be more sympathetic
with the safe some people any is with the
survivors who her way more hard-core during
that clip when he said he had some ideas about
what was going on with the staff he probably
just started using it as a nonlethal way to
deal with people at the walls of the end of
the last season which he totally should killed
is always like the external conflicts you
have on the show you don't them fighting the
governor fighting the walkers but then you
have the internal conflicts underneath that
fights between members inside the group so
the big fight this your current lease when
the season picks up is going to be Morgan's
philosophy versus Rex philosophy the exact
same thing went on inside Michelle like completely
localized her character where she started
out being super hard-core they got to the
Saison she hung her katana up and started
being sheriff be shown it was like she was
trying to leave behind her violent past is
like I don't need this anymore cut to the
end of the season where she takes it back
down which like okay yeah maybe I do need
it I think she's just the balance between
Rick and Morgan's philosophy so either they
find some sort of internal equilibrium or
the ship is going to hit the fan and is going
to tear the group apart that's usually what
you see happen with like Rex character where
he sees something else going on like some
other conflict and it makes them think about
what he's doing where is like oh my God I'm
on way to crazy now he hasn't quite reach
that point though your people were making
jokes about how BP basically turned into Shane
who is now officially the punisher by the
way that that's pretty big deal but I don't
think that Rick is Shane is just a funny way
to think about how short he's gotten with
situations rate just like nope not having
it going to shut this down old Rick would've
probably had several conversations with people
for came to blows Rick right now just has
no more time for bull ship if you do want
to read along in the comic book was season
six episode one will pick up right around
where volume 14 no way out picks up so you
can read ahead if you want or don't read it
your way they are doing more stuff from the
comics but remember it's still meditation
and a lot of the characters have been changed
to fit with the cast they have like that was
Monroe in the comics is this female leader
of the Saison so that gender been a few characters
they have people like Daryl who are in the
comics it all but we will be seeing storylines
from that comic it will be seeing locations
that they visit so if you want to know is
some of those are and you don't care about
potential spoilers just read ahead and the
comic back to the video so look around what's
going on in the background it looks like there
barricading the road with more stuff Michelin
is sitting under this 18 wheeler I don't know
if that belongs to the wolves or if it's just another
one they found in their using it to to barricade
the road with extra stuff but it looks like
they're expecting the wolves to come and they're
just preparing for or could just be routine
maintenance just looking at it this looks
like new construction though it's not like
the rebuilding walls too bad they don't have
an engineer anymore say little silent prayer
for D's husband the new pretty good job of
changing the dynamic on the show like every
half season so expect this first have to feel
very different from the second half of season
five but I don't think they're going to do
a repeat of season five episode one with a
blue up terminus in that first episode if
they do repeat anything I I'm really hoping
to see some more Rambo Carol Sasha's kind
of taken that role on herself she's, like
comic book Andrea sitting up in the tower
get the assault rifle so if anyone can be
mowing down any walkers is is probably can
be her right now though Carol is still my
favorite character she she is like the Colossus
of the group which is why it's so funny that
she dresses like a housewife it's on act you
know she's hiding behind those cookies those
very awesome scary cookies. My question for
you guys after the events of the finale who
is your favorite character on the show right
now it like what are you hoping to see from
them in the first episode Carol go crazy Sasha
mow the shit out of some people there aren't
a whole lot of wolves like actual human wolves
most of the bodies that they have are all
walkers like there's a couple wolves controlling
all them it's been a ton of money building
Daryl's custom bike I'm hoping they don't trash
that in the first episode either the only
problem with having so many awesome main characters
is that a lot of the lesser characters, get
put by the wayside when you big episodes in
their all in it together so like Carl and Enid
very interesting dynamic but the my not get
featured quite as much just because so much
is going on in this first episode I really
do expect a lot from units character she's
like one of the most fascinating young female
characters that we've seen on the show Lizzie
Mika were a lot of fun but they were like
way way younger by having a slightly
older teenage girl I think they can have someone
that will challenge Carl but someone that
he could also learn a lot from Beth was starting
to get there but she was almost like this
precious flower growing in the weeds so naturally
all the weeds were going to choke her out
at some point one of my other favorite new
Safe Zone characters is Aaron like Aaron Daryl
dynamic Aaron just using a really awesome dude
it it seems like he knows he should just as
well as Daryl I didn't enjoy like the really
awkward dinner scenes with with his boyfriend
quite as much just just went Daryl and Aaron
are off in the wilderness together just because
Daryl hates talking so much in Aaron kind of
gets that even though he presses
him all the time there so many odd pairings
on the show you have Carl and Enid you have
Rick and Morgan have Daryl and Carol I really
get into shipping or anything like that really
hard-core but is just it's so funny when you
see those characters together we Seo's odd
pairings like whenever there is an a lot of
action on screen that that's what's most fun
about the show so just a reminder about the comic
con panel that's going to be on Friday I'm going to do a big comic con preview where I talk
about when everything is going to be
happening they'll drop the trailer but it's
going to be two hours going to bring out the
entire cast of fear The Walking Dead too so
we'll probably learn a lot about that show
when we do get a little bit closer like us
but especially right around comic con I'll start
doing Q&A videos for The Walking Dead again
too and the weekly giveaway will start
up again, in fact i'll go ahead and get it started right now
all you to have to do to enter is be subscriber and leave
a comment on this video i'll announce the winner
when I post my next walking dead video
it should be by next week I've got a couple
other videos I'm working on for the weekend
you can find updates for that stuff on on
Twitter and Facebook links in the description if you
don't know where to find those so time
to start preparing yourself for fear The Walking
Dead and season six while you guys wait for my next
video you can click here for my fear The Walking
Dead trailer video and you can click here
for my season six predictions thank you so
much for watching, everybody let's high five
and I'll see you guys tonight!